420 qu'ont manifesté à londres
aujourd'hui pour réclamer le droit de
vivre selon leurs normes et leurs
coutumes et pour célébrer aussi la mort
du premier musicien punk vite chaud
devant les londoniens qui ont gardé leur
sang froid on avait passé des jeunes
filles aux cheveux rouges à pointe bleue
maquillé en jaune et en noir avec des
épingles à nourrice en guise de boucles
d'oreilles les garçons étaient à la
hauteur de la réputation punk avec des
chaînes de vélo en tour de tête des
boyaux des bicyclettes en guise de
ceinture des maquillages à l'encré de
chine des crânes rasés ou seul subsiste
et une touffe de cheveux peinte en rouge
1976 londres la bière le rock le diable
peut être des sex pistols sûrement qu on
inventait le mouvement punk signifie
pourri sans valeur depuis 20 ans qu'il
transforme le monde
le bon vieux rock'n roll ccif alors
c'est le grand nettoyage pacte
musicalement massacre les classiques du
rock mais le mouvement dépasse largement
le cadre musical pour s'attaquer à
l'établissement
johnny rotten déclare alors nous ne nous
sentons pas disposé à chanter des
chansons d'amour au milieu des queues
qui se forment devant les caisses de
chômage
convocation cheveux en couleurs épingle
à nourrice dans l'ajout cette génération
punk s'isole enfin passé qu'elle ignore
et un avenir qu'elle imagine
difficilement
en jeu